you guys see the uh you know glenn
greenwald resigned from the intercept
right you guys saw this this is crazy
but he put out this tweet that made me
laugh
um i'm not gonna name the guys but he
was like
something like how long until there's a
group like how long until we have
journalists
trying to get sex substantive people
and then he named two journalists who
literally just is like those are
journalists
right they're not they're activists true
and one of these guys i bring him up
because he tweeted you don't understand
we can't get the laptop to even report
it if we wanted to
and then you tweeted at him like i think
you tweeted at him i did yeah
here's the laptop i i've been offering
this to jake tapper
to anyone who would want to come in
mark cuban kind of responded but then he
said well no i don't want a copy of the
laptop i want the actual
one that was given to the fbi the double
standard is so
polite how am i supposed to do you folks
remember when there was this
this tweet slash led to an article
i don't remember which news station
exactly was but it was there was rumors
that a tape exists of trump yes
yeah it's like are you the elevator
absolutely insane there may
there may be a tweet people are maybe a
tape people are talking about
the two yes no one has seen no one has
never seen the tape i'm not sure if
there's actually tape
i don't know like maybe trump maybe he's
another maybe he's doing some stuff you
know kind of just doing
it
[Music]
for which journalists are willing to i
don't know
fact check when it comes to a trump
story versus a biden story are
completely free this is what tim just
said about about biden
i got it okay pull it up all right here
we go a tape might exist of trump doing
something in an elevator though exactly
where that somewhere
is and what that something might be no
one in media can say
that's because no one in media seems to
have seen the tape or is even confident
it exists oh my god
i have breaking news guys yes there may
be a photograph
of jack somewhere at some time doing
something oh snap
and it's really bad but i can't say that
definitively because i don't
know if it exists it's bad yeah they
don't even know that it's possibly bad
it like might just be like kind of off
color but you know
potentially devastating how did they
write this i don't know
dude you can say whatever you want about
donald trump on social media
you can literally come up with the most
outlandish
and she did just happened today
it was like the yale professor oh that's
right
and she said well you know i'm not even
going to say it because they're going to
you know immediately matter
you guys seen what sam harris was and
yeah yeah harrison
and now he's told him he's like it's out
of context
okay i got to wait just for people who
don't understand the context of horses
yes
there have been a couple of people sam
harris basically said that he thought
osama bin laden
and this is his opinion i got to be very
careful about sam's opinion
sam's sam harris's opinion is that uh
that man was better than trump in a lot
of ways
oh and there was also this professor who
said the same thing about hitler
and it's like you people have gone
insane
no sam harris also said that about
hitler and trump he was saying
that what makes trump worse than hitler
are actual is actually things like
courage and standing up for something
greater
than yours but that was that was the
best part because it was
it was the it was the first clip of that
that came out was just the osama bin
laden comment
and then and then sam said and then sam
goes well you're taking it out of
context and they say what did he say
after
he's like well now you're saying hitler
the context makes it worse sam yeah that
text makes it a little far
far worse and then he tweeted i think
social media is designed to
you know make things out of context or
whatever it is and everyone's just like
come on dude
yeah you've got trump directly if you if
you get to that point
where you're and can we stop comparing
things
to hitler like there was a hitler
seriously and he did terrible things
yeah what about stalin yeah stalin he
did terrible things right
and now terrible things pull pot
terrible things communication
is worse than mine and so like why are
we comparing
any contemporary you can't compare
they're all separate they all have their
own
you know they're they're different
levels of of
moral uh uh decay and
and horribleness yes that have gone on
and
you know you can't comp i said this
yesterday
if trump really was a fascist you
wouldn't be able to vote him out
you wouldn't be allowed to people don't
understand right but turpitude that's
the word i was thinking of
it's kind of similar to there was this
person
uh gosh i think she was a writer or is a
writer for the boston globe who compared
the
trump uh trucks to isis yeah
i don't i don't see a difference i used
to think that it was because they
thought trump was that bad maybe it's
just that they don't actually realize
how awful isis is
right maybe it's just like it's not that
they think trump is
genocidal or an actual fascist maybe is
that they think isis is bad
because they also implemented tax cuts
and wanted the islamic caliphate out of
the paris accord
like maybe they just don't understand
how bad those other people are
that but but you know it's it's kind of
funny but i think you're right when you
see how they do
like the um islam lgbt stuff like i had
a friend who had
a flyer for it was like a woman wearing
a hijab
and it said like you know activist-y
stuff and it was like rainbow flag
and i was just like i think the amount
of people and i'm not trying to be mean
anybody but i think the amount of people
who are
uh adherents to this religion who would
agree with that sign is probably very
very small
right very very very small especially
considering the planet
and i think we have like 1.2 billion um
muslim practitioners on the planet
right i would say the overwhelming
majority are gonna look at that and say
how dare you i mean because we saw this
in the uk when they had um
they would call it islamophobic actually
well this was really interesting in uh i
forgot i forgot what the uh town was
it was in the uk they were doing lgbt
curriculum
for kids and it was muslims who showed
up protesting right
yeah and that was like a really
confusing thing where like the lgbt
people were like i defend you and it's
like
i don't think you realize like these
religions are very very different from
what you're
proposing and so i think you're right i
think these people don't really know
what
isis wants or does or what their what
their you know faith tells them to do or
their perversion of it
and so they see a row of trucks with
trump flags they see a row of trucks
with isis flags and they're like
it's the same picture yeah i mean you
you've gotten uh
this set of people who have such a blind
spot when it comes to trump and trump
supporters that
they've reduced themselves to word
thinking
picture thinking um there's no
there's no depth anymore right there's
no critical thought there's no
understanding of
you know a line of trucks in when it
comes to isis and
you know like when i was in intel
community when isis was rowing and i
saw things that they were doing over
there and it's like
you really don't want to compare
anything
maybe like the only thing i could think
of possibly to compare isis to would be
like the zetas cartel
in in northern mexico which is like one
known as one of the absolute
most brutal cartels that's on the face
of the planet but it is a
purely emotional response for so many of
these people and with the whole sam
harris thing i remember asking in that
thread
what exactly is the context then because
i i'm sure you've all been taken out of
context more times than you can count
and obviously like a single sentence in
maybe an hour conversation isn't
necessarily representative of what you
mean
and i had so many sam harris supporters
who had listened to the podcast saying
well
you know at least those guys had a sense
of good or duty to something whereas
trump only cares for himself therefore
he's worth it's like
you're all you're doing is projecting
intention on to him
which you don't know right you can't
read his mind you can't read it but
it's there's there's two other things
it's not just out of context right so
a lot of people are familiar with that
if i say something like can you believe
jack told me he prefers you know jelly
donuts what a crazy guy
or or jack said to me i like jelly
donuts then they take the i like part
and attribute it to me even though i was
quoting
right that's the out of context there's
also uh there's also relevant like
musical context
they did this to me where i said i was
asked specifically
about oh i can't remember which which oh
yeah yeah there was a news story
and i think it was about kim.com or
something i can't remember
and someone asked me on a stream who do
you trust more
referring to the story the new york
times or you know
like dave rubin or something and i said
something about trusting dave rubin more
than i would the new york times but i
was referring to one specific story
so it's like you asked me you know does
dave rubin enjoy
you know eating out for dinner i would
say well i would trust dave over the new
york times then they took the cut
the clip where they ignore the context
around what was going on
so that's you know general context the
other thing they do is
uh i kind of lost my train of thought on
this one because i started talking about
other things funny enough is i've
actually been talking to people
about um about who they're going to vote
for in the election
and i've been having and i don't even
know how it started but people have just
been sending me these anonymous
conversion stories
and a good 90 of them are and i'll just
i'll just tell you one because the one
that really kicked it off
they said look i've i've been home a lot
um during covid during the lockdowns i'm
i'm considered non-essential so i've
been watching tv a lot more
i saw this thing where the media was
saying cnn was saying that trump said
that people should drink bleach
right and you know it's a recent one i
think it was june july or time frame
and and she said well i thought wow
that's crazy i want to watch that i want
to watch that clip
so i can laugh at it or something right
so she pulls up the clip
and then goes to the actual press
conference where he's talking about that
and said well wait a minute no that's
not what he said
at all but he was clearly talking about
the specific treatment
and then this is the amazing part then
the light bulb went off for her and she
said
maybe it's frozen please yeah have they
been lying about
other things as well and now she's like
a full full-bore
walk away trump supporter in
four months i remember what i was going
to say and now i'm losing it again oh no
there's a lot of instances where you'll
say something the left doesn't know
about
and then they'll take a clip of you
saying it post it all over and all these
leftists will be like i can't believe
that something so crazy because
they didn't know that thing was true i
can give you example that um
this guy miles taylor who's like this
this new like never trumpeter
he was anonymous yeah but um and he was
like this junior guy he
he said he said donald trump
actually suggested that we put illegal
migrants in guantanamo bay
how crazy is it that he said that well
if you actually understood anything
about the context of why guantanamo bay
was built
and the actual like tent city that was
there the original tent city at
guantanamo bay was built during
uh the the clinton administration
because there was an influx
of migrants from haiti and cuba that
were coming to the united states
and we had wetfoot dry foot which was
the u.s policy at the time
under clinton elia gonzalez of course
was a huge uh huge factor at that time
and they said we need a place to process
them
in the region hey why don't we use this
this navy base that we have at
guantanamo
and then one and then because some of
the migrants that came in
it was later discovered they had
criminal backgrounds or they had
problems with them
so they had to build a more secure
facility because they didn't want these
guys
just going around the rest of the tent
city and that's where camp x-ray comes
from
and so trump saying oh i want to put
migrants at
you know guantanamo oh it sounds
terrible it sounds horrible if you don't
know the actual historical context of
guantanamo bay
yeah yeah i've had people say uh cause i
because i got really angry and i said
something like if joe biden wins they're
gonna be coming to your house they're
gonna change definitions all of these
things
and then all these people are always all
these left to start sharing it not
realizing
i was specifically referring to things
that had already happened
and i'm like i wasn't predicting the
future i was saying this is what is
happening they're going to people's
homes
the point i was making was that trump is
stopping these or at least trying to
so it happens all the time like the uh
the coyote thing remember that
yes that was one of the best moments on
twitter ever
these people deserve awards but and what
was so frustrating about that is
all of the people who are saying coyotes
what's he talking about animals bring
over
you can just bet your bottom dollar that
these are also people who consider
themselves hardcore immigration
activists
which is so maddening because it clearly
demonstrates that they've done
absolutely zero research
into this actual topic i'm so well read
i i read the new york times cover to
cover every day
this is what's this is what's scary
about um it's interesting for
uh i believe everybody should have the
right to vote everybody if they decide
to vote should vote but i think it was
mike rowe who said this that
just because you have the right to do it
doesn't mean you should you have a right
to own guns doesn't mean you should not
everyone not everybody should
um so the left strategy is get as many
people as possible to vote
and what they end up doing is they end
up getting low information voters who
vote for things against their own
interests
while accusing the right of voting
against their own interests when at
least for now
it seems the right has more high
information voters or higher information
voters
so the challenge would be the democrat
or i should say the worrying thing is
you know how do you how do you solve for
an issue like that i saw a a video from
a friend where they were like look i'm
gonna go mail in my ballot because
donald trump is colluding with bill barr
to you know like
to to disrupt this democracy and i'm
like what are you talking about
like what what what bill bar are you
talking about i can talk about all the
obama gate stuff i can tell you
everything that bill barr won't do for
trump and trump's complaining about it
but you saw something on cnn so you went
out and voted and now you're voting
against your own interests
because if you're worried about
democracy being destroyed it's
the democrats doing it the republicans
are playing by the rules they might be
cutthroat
but packing the courts changing the
election rules that's that that's that's
cheating it's all cheating
so if we're gonna lose democracy it's
coming from them but i guess i guess the
point i'm making is
how do you like what do you do in a
society where you have the manipulation
of low information people to vote
service guaranteed citizens i know yeah
starship jubilee
yeah no but it it is concerning and i
i have so many libertarian friends who
are very i guess like
laissez faire and this actually also
applies to to people on the left as well
when it comes to things like voting and
democracy just like yeah we'll do
whatever and i don't think people
understand that
you know it what the will of the
majority is is not necessarily something
that's
good and what really boggles my mind is
that so many leftists now talk about how
the electoral college is undemocratic as
if it's like this flaw that the founding
fathers didn't know about it's like no
this is explicitly by design they did
not want mob rule
and i find it very strange in the past
four years
and i think this is because hillary
clinton won the popular vote how there's
this
this focus in the left with talking
specifically about democracy they're not
talking about liberty
they're talking very explicitly
specifically about democracy and i think
it is because they're trying to change
the paradigm
and the purpose of government to not
just be to protect and safeguard rights
individual liberties
but to you know carte blanche whatever
it may be
represent the will of the people for
better or worse
i'll go one further uh in a sense but
not
so much on voting rights but actually
something that like nobody talks about
it in these terms i don't know why
and it's we mentioned it earlier um but
the idea that so good magnifying fathers
united states
um they gave us an election day
it was a day yes you hold the election
there's a certain period of hours
the election ends it is one day it is
not this and
you know coming from the state of
pennsylvania we've never had early
voting the way we have it now
um the way they're adding in all these
new rules and all these changes
and look i get that we're in a pandemic
everything else but they gave us an
election day for a reason
because they and you can go in and find
the debates about this where they were
saying that
you know the more you open the aperture
the more
problems you run into the more issues
you run into the more questions about
you know who like
like we've had elections during
pandemics before in this country we had
all the revolution during pandemic
actually
um we've we've gone through you know the
spanish flu we still had an election
um during those time frames and so it's
it's this idea
that you can keep widening the aperture
for you know
as they said before all all ballots have
to be counted all ballots but then
you're changing the definition of what
that means
you're changing the value of what that
means because you're sending them to all
people rather than people who have
decided
on their own as you just said that um
maybe some people don't
or don't intend to vote right are they
still getting a ballot why are they
getting about what are they doing with
that ballot right and you can you can go
through the permutations like
i know people don't want to vote who
said i'm not voting did they get
yes of course see so what so what is
that what happens to that ballot and
then what if x amount of
those people and you know you can go you
can you can play that out in any way in
a number of ways we already saw that
story i remember which date it was where
i think
maybe new jersey where someone stole
mail and ballots from someone's mailbox
yep
so if you're if you didn't request it
you're not looking for it what happens
when someone steals it
now this guy was just male right let's
say
and total scenario blah blah blah
hypothetical all the disclaimers
you know but let's say you see a house
let's do it this way
let's say you're you know which one the
biden house is you know which one the
trump house is and you know that a bunch
of mail-in ballots are going there
and then you see the flag up on that
mailbox you take them from the trump
house
and i mean like how how do we know
that's not going on but see the thing
and to play devil's advocate
for a little bit the people on the left
will say there's no evidence of this
happening
you know there's maybe only been a
handful of times but i think the fact
that this is even a possibility is in
and of itself a flaw in the system yes
because a flaw in the system isn't just
if it's actively being exploited it's
just the fact that it could be so easily
exploited and maybe this will be the
first time yeah yeah why why would we
open
it you at least guard against that
exactly unlock your door and keep it
open
there's no evidence of widespread crime
in our neighborhood there's no evidence
the sun rev
the earth revolves around the sun
there's no evidence of that
shut up copernicus burn you at the stake
burn copernicus before you get the
telescope out of here throw it in the
river
before he tells everyone what's really
happening so uh
riots oh yeah what do you think's gonna
happen
so uh like liam who's also my fiance and
produces
our show we are kind of at odds right
now because i want to i want to go
and i want to get some juicy footage no
no no no no
at least from a distance see what i'm
there's definitely going to be protests
and i i think i'm okay to go and film
protests i think there absolutely will
be riots though and it's funny because
i've seen so many people on social media
saying that oh you trump supporters
aren't going to take the loss well as if
any of these store owners are boarding
up their
their stores or you know their homes or
anything like that against trump support
but
not only that are they going to vote for
the democrats could you imagine being
like well this guy raised money to bail
out the rioters and now i'm boarding up
my store better go vote for him i think
there are people who are doing that
that's insane there are there absolutely
i just i just bought a bunch of guns now
i'm gonna vote for the guy who's gonna
take him away yeah that makes sense
no but have you guys seen the piece uh
from the atlantic
uh kind of arguing that the best way to
stick it to
antifa is by voting for brighton
it was uh was it yahshua yes yeah i
think so and i mean that's kind of
essentially what people
like sam harris and i i love her but
helen pluck rose are all
no they're wrong they're wrong the
people in new york
the people in new york who are attacking
vehicles on the highway
young children and who pepper sprayed
children were not antifa and far
leftists they were regular progressives
who are just violent lunatics who pepper
sprayed children
yep that's why i was going to say it was
jewish children too yes
you shouldn't go out and cover anything
i would say look
look said liam the reason why i stopped
going out and this is years ago
is because they track who these
journalists are
so you even that's what i was thinking
because now people are wearing masks
outside
yeah and it's crazy that i even need to
think about it but the last time i was
like
on the ground was in hamilton canada
where there was that antifa thing
yelling at the elderly couple
uh you know i saw people getting tackled
and stuff that day before that
tommy robinson liam almost had to fight
someone who didn't want him filming and
it's just
i don't know i'm kind of jaded against
it i know that sounds really bad but
it's like if you want to be
even if you go masked at this point
they're they'll come they'll come after
you for filming regardless yeah
even after your match and it's going to
be i think the worst we've seen they did
it to ford fisher the other day and he
had to like
the camera's at your feet my camera's at
your feet you know and they they
surrounded it
yeah it doesn't matter elijah got
punched in the face
yeah yeah yeah elijah shafer yeah they
don't care anymore
um i think but don't you think they're
gonna be regular do you think they're
going to be regular people who are also
just kind of protesting a la woman's
march or do you think it's just going to
be full-on writing
well you know you know wait do you know
what happened until you know lukowski
yeah we are changed do you know what
happened uh so you didn't hear the story
about having him in the g20
he was so in in hamburg i was in hamburg
uh luke was there
luke was walking down the street with a
german journalist
there was a photograph of luke walking
with this guy mark and lauren southern
was in the background
from that photo they started tracking
down anybody who was seen in it
someone saw luke and started yelling i
think i think it's nazi schweinhund
i think it's what they were yelling and
random people who were sitting down got
up and ran up and started punching him
in the face and punching them all over
they weren't antifa they were just
regular people sitting there and they
heard someone yell nazi so they gotta go
oh and they started punching
just beating them knocking them down
they got bloodied up and then the emts
came in
and then you know so yeah it's gonna be
regular people
but if one person walks up and screams
it's a nazi it's a nazi regular people
are going to go full mob mentality
i mean see i've never even like i don't
have that
in me right if someone runs up and
screams nazi screams communist
you know and i'm just sitting eating a
meal right
like you're not gonna drop everything
yeah i'm gonna say oh that's interesting
i guess
and then i'm just gonna go back to my
meal because it you know
what what is it that's that's because
you're a normal person oh right right
especially you know if i'm with my wife
or my kid or something like like
can you go do that over there maybe well
if but these like so if people go to a
protest
and like let's say there's some regular
person they're a barista for a living
and they have the day off and their
friends like oh there's gonna be a big
protest and they go oh i'll come then
someone yells it's a nazi
and then that person goes and just runs
up and starts swinging and screaming
like these people totally lose their
minds a mob
i mean this and this is a question about
mob mentality but a mob is
only as smart as the stupidest person
and then it's yeah
and the minute that the minute that
person starts screaming something and
this is something it's it's biological
we're wired this way
right with you know monkey see monkey do
like it's it's it's real right it's all
it goes
it's very developmental and that
you know we are social creatures we we
and when you get
into one of those situations it's it's
very hard to fight that internal
programming um and it's very easy to
just go along with it this is what my
people are doing this is what my tribe
is doing this is
this is an outsider this is a this is a
parasite this is a virus this is a
threat we need to stop the threat we
need to get away
and then that's that's where you see
some of those impulses come from
well i guess the question for both of
you would be then how do you
stop this because i think i think there
is a certain kind of primal biological
instinct within us when someone says
you know fire or attack or whatever we
we want to participate but i think it's
also true that
20 years ago this kind of thing wasn't
happening so clearly there's been some
kind of escalation so
you know even if trump does win how do
we how do we make it not acceptable to
punch people in the face because we
disagree with them like is it more
accountability
someone should write a song about this
yeah well they sure should yeah
uh well the issue is that you've got
i don't know what the factions are in
the culture war or whatever
but i'll tell you this there's a bunch
of different dividing lines it's not
just one side versus the other side
there's like overlaps and it's probably
more like some kind of circle
but as long as for the most part the
left has the media
saying it's good to punch people you
don't like they're gonna keep doing it
there's no comeuppance there's no
penalty there's no punishment
so they'll do it what are they going to
worry about jack if you defended
yourself they'd make you the bad guy
yeah so when people talk about that uh
you know i had some people at the right
so i got i got a you know sort of
similar situation happened to me i go to
cover an event they said they're going
to tear up
a good photo though
they you know they said they're going to
tear down a statue of abraham lincoln
like down the street from our studio in
dc so i said well
i you know i want i wanted to go see
that and just film it right and so it
was really interesting situation because
and i've told the story a million times
but there you know there ended up
actually being people who were
descendants of some of the freedmen the
freed slaves who had donated to
erect that statue of abraham lincoln
which actually predates the lincoln
memorial so this
actually was the original lincoln
monument in washington dc frederick
douglass dedicated like literally fred
frederick douglass dedicated this statue
right and so you could tell that even
though the protesters
were like an sjw lefty kind of crowd
that
they were they were kind of not really
on board with taking it down
they were like there's like like it just
didn't work something you know that's
cognitive dissonance right
they could tell that wait why are we
taking out a statue of abraham lincoln
like this doesn't seem right and and you
can see that that
cognitive dissonance and so i get
identified by
a certain member of antifa who i'm not
going to name due to litigation
but um we know who he is
and then uh same situation goes out
and i just did my ground i literally
just stood my ground and people on the
right have said
well jack why didn't you defend yourself
because they tried to push me down these
stairs
um which are concrete and there's like a
concrete floor at the bottom where
they're trying to kind of knock me down
onto them
they said why don't you swing why didn't
you take flight back waiting to find
yourself said well
number one i've got a kid
you know he's gonna watch that video
someday and i don't want him to
see his father using violence to solve
something that doesn't require violence
i mean i just didn't think it was it
warranted it at that point nothing they
did really
really warranted it even though they did
they were pushing and shoving and
punching me
um but but also that i knew
that media takes it out of context that
that
jake tapper and oliver darcy and media
matters and all those guys
are gonna clip it just like somebody did
in uh los angeles it goes beverly hills
recently
um where they they clip this thing where
a guy gets swarm attacked by these
black-clad
anarchists and then after and then they
they take away he's carrying an american
flag and armenian flag
and they take it from him and then he he
gets it back they pummel him on the
ground
then finally they pull themselves off
and then he goes and like runs after and
hits one guy
so antifa clips the video where he just
runs up and hits the one guy and then
they accuse me
because i shared the full video and then
they accused me
of sharing they called it a strategical
edit video
um because and i said wait a minute no
no my video
includes that part where he does run up
and strike one of the other ones i
didn't cut that out that's why my video
is longer than your video
that's how that works right you
strategically edited it but you're
missing the context
of they were beating this guy within an
inch of his life well i mean it's
similar to the whole
kyle written house thing yeah two
million dollar bail they just said it
two million two million [ __ ]
buckarinos
wow yeah i was reading an article he was
extradited i think yeah today
actually it's really interesting uh vice
wrote an article asking if we were in a
civil war
uh sort of concluding we are saying
experts have said
that we are in a civil war and they say
things like their justification for why
it is is that killers like kyle
rittenhouse are lauded by their
political allies
and it's really funny when i read that
because i was like um
kyle rittenhouse is lauded because he
fled first
he tried fleeing which he was supposed
to do and then only when someone fired a
gun did he turn around and defend
himself from an attack
and then immediately tried to get the
police he was lauded for doing
everything correctly
whereas michael reinel stalked and
assassinated
a trump supporter yep and then and that
guy is lauded by the far left um
actually by vice
yes literally ironically
yeah yikes man that's why like any time
someone gets mad at you for doing in
like a
controversial interview i mean people
like vice literally
interview killers yeah right who have
killed people i don't care how
unchallenged yeah
just like tell me what happened thank
you and have a good day exactly like you
can at least ask
but that's but that gets into what we're
talking about too because our entire
moral framework has been flipped
in this country where where words
and ideas have become the greatest moral
crimes
and then something like murder is
considered well all you do is murder
somebody
it's like but he was a trump supporter
it's like that interview of jeffrey
dahmer that jeffrey dahmer gave where he
kept trying to tell the person look i
just want you to know i'm not racist
it's like literally jeffrey dahmer but
even jeffrey dahmer think about that but
really think about that
in his moral framework he really wanted
to make sure that people didn't know he
was racist
even though he had killed all those
people yeah yeah but he killed people of
all colors but it wasn't real
it wasn't really yeah it wasn't racially
motivated just want to just want to keep
that clear everybody
yeah and that's good then i guess
according to like like right it's like
but think about the worst moral crime
was avoided so
the worst mobile crimes were so this
gets you into all of these various like
the sam harris thing
and all those other ideas that kind of
similar to when uh
it looked like kim jong-un might be dead
and so so many people were saying like
oh look north korea a female leader
how progressive really i feel like you
know
there's there's a lot more to this
the gulags need to be over overseen by a
woman yeah that way it's progressive
yes yes thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you